[ضحك]
[موسيقى]
مرحبا ضجه كبيره بدات مع بدء عرض مسلسل
الفلوجه في تونس ومطالبات بايقاف العمل
ابرزها كانت من وزاره التربيه بمصالح
القانونيه واللي رفعت دعوه تطالب بمراجعه
العمل وحذف مشاهد اعتبرتها مسيئه للمؤسسات
العموميه وللمربين والتلاميذ على حد سواء
بصراحه كل صدق ما كملتوش ما كملتوش على
خاطر انا حسيتو المسلسل هذايا
ماهوشوا فيه انا فهمتني مع كل من
طالب بدعوه الى ايقاف هذا المسد لانه يسيئ
منه ويسيء من شبيبتنا ومن تلاميذه النوب
المؤسسه التربويه خاصه هو المسلسل فيه
الواقع التونسي راه
احترام على خاطر عبيد في رمضان تجيب حاجات
محترمه بدها تجيب حاجه تعقل التربيه
اي مسلسل اي فيلم
الرقابه هذيك قبل ما يخرج العباد
ممثلين ما شاء الله عليهم اوكي موضوع حساس
وكل صاير كله صاير في تونس بالعكس انا
وتعيش فيه في الحقيقه كامل درامي يوصل
الواقع واصل
المخبي
المسلسل يتحدث عن الظواهر والسلوكيات في
المدارس على غرار ترويج المخدرات
والعلاقات العاطفيه والعنف ودور رجال
الامن فيما يحصل في محيط المدارس وعلاقه
المراهقين باوليائهم مواضيع اعتبرها البعض
ليست جريئه بل المدعيه
هذا حمله المسؤوليه للشباب هما بيدهم محمد
المسؤوليه للعائلات قمه المسؤوليه زاده
المؤسسه التربويه مشيت في جماليه جماليه
اللي جملت الواقع بالحق جملته علي موجود
خطر اللي موجود
اقصى واصعب وامروا وخايب اكثر من كيكه
فهمت ويفجع اكثر وسائل التواصل الاجتماعي
املات بردود الفعل ما
بينظوميه الاخلاق للمجتمع وما بين مؤيد
يراه انتاج قريب من الواقع ويعكس الصور
الحقيقيه للمجتمع دون تزييف ولا يشكل اي
خطر على الشباب الناشئ زين
[موسيقى]
اكل هكذا
انا قررت
[تصفيق]